bom os objetivos da minha pesquisa é
fortalecer a pesquisa na área da música
contemporânea brasileira é é aqui na
universidade a gente tem um um acúmulo
de materiais é europeus e americanos e
brasileiro ainda está um pouco escasso
então esse é um dos meus objetivos é o
segundo objetivo é analisar a obra
integral para violão do compositor de
nuclear
aí ele ainda está vivo aí e analisar
quais foram os procedimentos que ele
utilizou na sua escrita composicional
que foi foram inovadores assim pela
linguagem
o terceiro objetivo é elaborar materiais
didáticos que tornem mais acessíveis à
música contemporânea brasileira tem em
vista que ela não é veiculada nos
grandes meios de mídia meio de
informações então é tornar isso mais
acessível e quebrar um pouco a
elitização da música e o quarto ponto é
difundir essa produção brasileira
comprando materiais com a reserva
técnica da bolsa e do ano para a
biblioteca do cmc é aqui do lado bom
o edi no crime ele nasceu em brusque
santa catarina em 1928 e hoje ele é
considerado com os mais um dos mais
importantes compositores brasileiros na
atualidade
a obra dele é bem vasta e tem peças para
orquestra sinfônica banda sinfônica cura
que essa de cordas e vozes solistas
música para cinema aquele filme meu pé
de laranja lima antigo ele que fez a
trilha sonora curiosidade
bom eu fiz um levantamento sobre
pesquisas é acerca de dino criei aqui em
são paulo e daí percebi que não tinha
nenhuma de mestrado e doutorado não
tinha nada tinha mais do villa lobos que
é um compositor
vasco e do almeida prado que foi
professor da unicamp desde não peguei
nada então isso o motivou a continuar
essa pesquisa com um ponto que me chamou
a atenção na obra para violão de dino
clique foi a utilização de novas
sonoridades por exemplo utilizar o
violão como um instrumento de percussão
ou fazer ruídos e sons que muitas vezes
não são tão bonitinhos assim ele e lhe
trouxe à tona e tentou sistematizar isso
através de uma anotação gráfica novos
símbolos de partitura para descrever
essa sonoridade é essa busca não é bem
assim é uma busca da música
contemporânea a partir do da segunda
metade do século 20 e que trouxe um
questionamento sobre a escuta sobre a
percepção musical é por exemplo um
compositor importante desse período foi
de john cage que fez uma composição
chamada 4 e 33 que era 4033 de silêncio
não tinha nota nenhum onde ele discutia
é a percepção dos ruídos da da sociedade
de toda a sonoridade que tem a nossa
volta que passa despercebido
bom a obra integral da dívida grega é
consiste em dez peças ao integral para
violão não é nem todas são para violão
solo algumas são para violão e orquestra
é violão e violino do de violões e
cordas
bom essas novas sonoridades que ele
trouxe na obra dele a gente chama de
técnicas estendidas que são basicamente
uma uma expansão da técnica tradicional
que a forma de tocar tradicional que é
expandida e também tem o termo técnica
expandida que seriam algo bem diferente
do tradicional que não tem relação com a
forma tradicional de tocar por exemplo
você pegar uma colher de sopa e
entrelaçam
z fazer com que ela vibra assim essa
sonoridade a gente chama de técnica
expandida não é encontrada na obra dele
na obra dele a gente vai encontrar as
técnicas estendidas que derivam de uma
técnica tradicional bom as quatro obras
que as técnicas estendidas estão
presentes são a hit mata e 74 concerto
para dois violões e orquestra de 1994
passar calha para frete na idéia e
alternâncias
então eu vou mostrar pra vocês alguns
trechos dessas peças como que ele
escreveu essas partituras e como que
isso só através do áudio aqui
o bom é vocês podem ver aqui na nesse
trecho aqui
essas três letras aqui significam anelar
médio indicador que são os dedos da mão
direita na nossa legenda para violão
nesse trecho aqui ele está utilizando ao
invés da mão direita na boca do violão
onde a gente precisa utilizar ele
entregasse os braços e vai utilizar na
no braço do violão
esse é um exemplo de técnica estendida
uma técnica uma forma tradicional de se
tocar aqui que foi é colocada de maneira
diferente lado esquerdo
o próximo exemplo que eu vou mostrar o
conceito para dois violões e cordas
nesse exemplo a gente conseguiu
é ver um pouco como o vilão foi
utilizado como um instrumento de
percussão que é uma característica de
técnicas estendidas o terceiro exemplo
que eu gostaria de mostrar a passar
calha para fred na área
hum
meu
o pedindo que ninguém trouxe à tona
algumas é concepções estéticas que
surgiram
é pós guerra e foram inevitáveis assim e
aqui eu queria mostrar as notações que
ele utilizou esses símbolos ele tentou
criar uma sistematização dessas novas
sonoridades que ainda não tinha ele
inventou alguns símbolos que descreveu
essa sonoridade que foram muito
importantes da literatura no passado
bom a última partida é no meu projeto e
elaboração de estudos didáticos é o
trabalho na escola livre de música da
unicamp
então eu desenvolvi alguns estudos
didáticos que aborda essas concepções
estéticas e técnicas também então eu
elaborei sete estudos e eu coloquei um
trechinho só da partitura de cada um só
comum uma uma demonstração assim então
eu estudo ele vai trabalhar elementos
que diz não crer utilizou de arpejos o
estudo dois também o estudo 3 ele vai
desenvolver concepções do minimalismo na
música estudo 415 é um estudo do
decafonis que foi uma técnica elaborada
por ano o time volta de 1912 por aí
o estudo 61 estudo 7 bom
a conclusão desta pesquisa é que obra
para violão de núcleo enriquece muito a
literatura no violão através dessas
novas sonoridades anotações e que existe
uma carência de materiais didáticos que
qd apresentem essas concepções estéticas
já estão se passando 100 anos e já a
gente não tem muito
muitos materiais que apresentem isso o
que a tornará elitizado uma obra
integral da dívida grega está aqui na
biblioteca já acessível a qualquer um
pode ir lá e acessar assim como de
outros compositores que eu também estou
colocando lado de james correia harry
crowl entre outros vocês podem acessar
conhecer tem cds para escutar também
junto com a certeza e é isso obrigado